[Musique]
si et entonné le célèbre thème musical
de john berry ce n'est pas pour annoncer
l'arrivée de james bond mais plutôt
l'ouverture du festival du film
documentaire saint-quentin spécial
musique
[Musique]
chicken run roméo et juliette sister act
et rabbi jacob
en bon nombre de musiques de films sont
passés entre les mains de l'orchestré
d'harmonie monty will orchestra
le célèbre compositeur vladimir cosma
était le grand attendu de la soirée
il a ainsi témoigné de son amour de la
musique mais aussi du cinéma ça me
semble important parce que ça et le
cinéma c'est un art c'est un art l'art
suprême parce que justement il mélange
la littérature le scénario le jeu des
acteurs l'image les décors la musique
tout ça vladimir cosma compositeur de la
musique du film les aventures de rabbi
jacob
en 1973 a même pris plaisir à retrouver
sa baguette le temps d'un morceau
[Musique]
il n'était pas loin de 200 spectateurs
et passionné a participé à la soirée
d'ouverture du festival passionnés
particulièrement de musiques de films et
j'adore quand on les enchaîne comme ça
le plaisir de retrouver les morceaux et
et puis particulièrement le talent de
l'année à venir que ça j'aime bien la
musique de la dmr cosma et comme ma
femme a trouvé justement l'opportunité
de venir ce soir en écoute et ben j'en
ai profité de l'occasion le festival
propose une programmation haute en
musique puisque des classiques comme
chantons sous la pluie ou mamma mia sont
diffusés aux côtés des films
documentaires en compétition
la remise des prix a lieu à 16 heures
dimanche 19 novembre au ciné cet élan
cool